[Music]
okay just got done seeing a good one was
called VFW yeah I liked it this kicked
ass I really really like I suspected I
was going to like it like before I even
saw it wanna like even when I saw the
trailer I'm like oh yeah that looks like
rendered off of off of Xbox I think it's
399 in standard definition and it really
it doesn't need to be in HD because they
filmed it like an old 80's movie
yeah and you can tell that they're kind
of homage and John Carpenter big time
it's got a John Carpenter sound and
soundtrack just the writing it's kind of
like precinct assault on precinct 13
mixed with escape from New York
and that's probably in and yeah it's
pretty good it's I I saw I was watching
Kody leach he movie a review of it
earlier and he also [ __ ] loved this
movie and he's trying to like hype it up
and get more people to watch it yeah
yeah he basically said assault on
precinct 13 Meets The Expendables yeah
that's about a bunch it's about the
bunch of old vets hanging out in a VFW
and this girl named lizard who is four
in some gang drug gang across the street
steals she steals a bunch of drugs and
runs in there for protection they were
trying to catch her and but they didn't
know what the hell's going on they were
just kind of duty about bound to protect
her so then it turns into kind of like
assault on precinct 13 yeah it's like I
see sh ty yeah they're under siege in
there and they're mostly unarmed they
got a couple of guns but they got a make
you know they're Vietnam veterans so
they're making a damn Vietnam punji
spikes and [ __ ] traps and it's pretty
cool all pretty much all-star cast from
B movies back in the day man the cast of
this kiss perfect incredible spot-on I
can't believe they got like all these
[ __ ] people in this way just waiting
the [ __ ] names so they got like the
main guy that plays Fred who owns the
VFW that's Stephen Lang Roy's bucket he
kicks ass in this yes that dude is 67
years old in that movie damn is looking
good for his first almost I mean I was
like watching this review and the
Ricochet the review said he should be
doing exercise yeah cuz he's like
[ __ ] almost 70 years old he looks off
prison
[ __ ] yeah short here he was in well he
was in don't breeze also which was
really good [ __ ] he was going he was a
man hunter he was in [ __ ] tune his
own he was an avatar he's been at all
kind of [ __ ]
they got the guy from the shaft movies
the old [ __ ] what was his name did you
know he wasn't in shaft he was in like
Fred Williamson he was in he used to be
a football player like a long time ago
and then he was in like a [ __ ] ton of
blaxploitation maybe yeah that's a shaft
movies he was in like a whole bunch of
them he must have been something come
through lady because she did a little
quick kung-fu [ __ ] thing is just look
he's in it William Sadler who was in
Shawshank Redemption yeah die hard
Martin Cove the villain from the Karate
Kid movie yeah yeah he's it from Co he
did great coke yeah David Patrick Kelly
who was in command oh yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah George went from Cheers
yeah he's in this as well it's just this
is the [ __ ] and the cast is like
amazing now the coolest thing I mean
there's a lot of cool things about this
movie this was directed by um Joe Bay
ghosts I think I'm pronouncing that
right he also did Bliss which we
reviewed prep probably a couple months
ago because they just dropped it on
shudder that came out in 2019
I liked bliss but this you can tell it's
the same director but this is like light
years better yeah it goes right in there
with a really good John Carpenter movie
yeah I'm back in the essentially like a
throwback yeah I mean like basically
it's like a super easy setup it's like
there's this unspecified town which is
just like gone to [ __ ] like everything
closed a cop in a band yeah the cops
won't come it's kind of like a it's kind
of like Detroit they're talking about a
situation like Detroit right and so it's
there's nothing around and then there's
this abandoned movie theater and there's
like a bunch of like drug punks like
there's rockers yeah there's very
typical looking yeah it's like just well
just like from the 80s like they're the
villains and stuff and you know there's
this new street drug that's called hype
and they deal it out of there and it
kind of turns people into zombies so
much like assault on precinct 13 we're
like the hoods that are like coming and
attacking the thing or like they don't
talk and like they're like zombies and
[ __ ] there's a look there's an aspect of
that too because
like the I mean the main drug dealer
who's I think the character's name is
Baz and um he's so he has like all these
druggies just go over there and try to
attack the VFW to get the drugs back
yeah that lizard has stolen now she
stole them because her sister no the
sister was the one that splattered at
the beginning it says I'm saying she was
yeah she was involved in it she was on
that drug and dude well I don't want to
spoil everything about yeah I mean that
that was like very very early in the
minute that was like the inciting the
drug makes you kind of mindless slave
yeah to the [ __ ] and might at one point
the bad guys like yeah they might be
mine they might be a mindless army of
slaves basically was like but they're
still an army and he's [ __ ] tell them
to go [ __ ] go get the drugs back you
know that they'll just wade in to
[ __ ] gunfire and you know they don't
give us yeah because they don't know
what they're stupid on then you can tell
them to jump off a [ __ ] building and
they will you know they'll just do
anything and it's kind of campy but it's
supposed to be because that's the that's
the tone of these movies just trying to
make an early 80s action sci-fi horror
movie even though you could say this is
kind of like a remake of assault on
precinct 13 in a way visually it
reminded me a lot of the darker scenes
from the fog so still carpenter but it
kind of reminded me of the fog that
movie you know at night remember they
showing like the cityscape or the town
at night with the fog coming kind of
like that but it's just waves of punk
rockers and I have to yeah and I have to
say to you that I really really like I
really really like the like the
production design like on the inside of
the VFW like the bar like you got a
colors good like the red green blue
lights and it's like really dark and
it's like just really cool like
atmosphere you know that was kind of
reminded me of the lighthouse slash
radio station that what's her name was
broadcaster yeah Adrienne Adrienne
Barbeau from the fog it kind of reminded
of course you know this is a lot bigger
but I was getting that feeling that I
got when I would see Adrienne Barbeau do
[ __ ] DJ routine in that in that
lighthouse it kind of felt that way
inside the VFW Post it felt like it was
you know like a protected space like a
bastion like it this the safe zone but
it was being attacked you know threat
it's just a certain calm tone he was
able to yeah to evoke you know him and
you know carpenter evoke that and added
the fog for me and like I said it seemed
like Joe Vegas is first I think bliss
was actually a second movie because I
think he made one in 2015 called the
mind's eye like a sci-fi movie which I
haven't seen like I said we did see
bliss which I liked but this is like way
way better it has a similar look it has
a similar kind of like punk rock DIY
kind of scuzzy underground kind of feel
about it just like kind of those old
movies where it's just like scummy
exploitation happening in one location
pretty much like one location it's just
it's essentially like an abandoned movie
theater and then like the VFW bar in
between the street in between my shrunk
out back they got old Deuce and a half
out back yeah 50 Cal but no ammo for it
but I mean there's just so much so I
made the cast like I said is amazing the
chemistry between all of the guys like
some of most of our Vietnam vets but I
think one guy was a Korea event and then
they also have like a younger guy showed
up it comes in from Afghanistan yeah and
so you know so it's not so much just
like an old farts versus like young
people so they do have like young people
that kind of like he'll play it one
thing I did like about it is that they
did not compromise that even the
morality behind the movie was eighties
traditional morality about loyalty and
you know what I mean and being you know
being a strong heroic figure and beat
you know being willing to die for your
friends that is what this movies about
and even further because they didn't
know lizards yes busted in they said
that they were duty-bound to protect her
and then all and then they saw that all
these like [ __ ] heads were like trying
to come get her and they're like okay
well you're not coming together they
didn't know who she was or what was
going on or anything so I'm glad that
the director just he didn't compromise
on them on the morality aspects of the
old-fashioned [ __ ] 80s movies that
they were and and I think it's a good
message this is it because it's a true
message it's true that's the way
veterans are many people should be
honestly as much as I love and like I
said this movie I think it's only 87
minutes 90 minutes long and it is lean
and mean it fun starts there's like
splatter from like the first two minutes
and then it really doesn't let up like I
said it's a very simple practical
effects the hallways story the [ __ ]
gore yeah is fans pretty good has
exploded arms chopped off it's so
[ __ ] fun it's action and thrills
through the whole thing what's spraying
everywhere it's not supposed to be like
realistic necessarily it's got that same
eighties come yeah it's just over the
top he's like people getting killed with
[ __ ] buzz saws and necks concrete
circular saw people with traps with
spikes and like a judge people getting
their heads blown off with shot almost a
borderline comic-book movie it is kind
of a certain shots look like something's
taken from a frame out of a comic book
Oh fat guy they're from [ __ ] from
cheers from with the damn concrete
cutter in a wave of but is I have to say
though as much as [ __ ] fun as that
was we were of course like drinking and
watching this we just had a [ __ ]
blast with this movie as [ __ ] great
as the gore is I'm telling you that I
could probably watch an entire movie of
just the grizzled old veteran sitting
there talking [ __ ] yes a bar the kind of
light humor it was good it's good here
they're just like all the [ __ ] about
like those strippers [ __ ] hair and like
oh [ __ ] yeah and it's just like and
there was there's not like a lot of that
like there aren't like a lot of slow
scenes or character development type
scenes or anything like that but you get
a sense of each of their personalities
like very quickly like just from the the
banter between them it's just what made
those older movies great he's brought
that back I could this director what's
his name again
Joe Vegas Joe Vegas Joe you could just
continue to make movies like this yeah I
watch them off like I'd buy this and on
blu-ray and now I kind of want to go
back and see
first one the minds I like you know as
we said and we might have said this I
can't remember what exactly we said when
we reviewed bliss which was the movie
that he did before this one which I
liked but I thought it could have been
like snapped up some but this one was is
definitely like a huge step forward and
score was spot-on
yeah it's just [ __ ] great score great
music like everything about it like
visually it's just really really cool
like dark with all this black bright
colored lights and you had giallo type
lighting and had a John Carpenter style
score that I just [ __ ] that it evoked
it evoke to the [ __ ] the genre yeah
that's it's just like a really cool like
scuzzy ballsy yeah eighties stop gory
like 80s style and I don't know I don't
think it was actually supposed to be in
80s it might be a parallel universe 80s
they didn't have cellphones that wasn't
yeah we couldn't really figure out
because we were figuring out the
veterans were like is this supposed to
be in the future because well he came
back from Afghanistan yeah that guy came
back from Afghanistan so it had to be
like right around this time period yeah
like you said nobody had cell phones
right so I kind of feel like maybe this
was just like an alternate reality maybe
been that helped you anyway because
there were no cut no police served no
cops yeah in that area so yeah because
there was a whole thing where like we
you know somebody that's wounded and
they had to go to the hospital they're
like well I couldn't get him out of it
they couldn't get about this like we
can't call the cops or amulets cuz they
won't come so yeah and they're killing
each other with wild abandon just out in
the open you know know with you know no
repercussions yeah I'm just gonna kill
that [ __ ]
and you know the cops do you know it's
it's outside it's happening outside the
sphere of law and order it's just you
know it's funny you know I guess that's
what it would have been because there's
no cops yeah it reminded me very much it
had kind of like that whole like Bronx
warriors yeah yeah it don't do like all
this kind of 80s movies where it's just
like dad fights gang fights out millon
oh wow the villain didn't like no cops
no Beverly nobody ever gets in trouble
but yeah it is kind of like that but
seriously I'm sure that's available on
some other streaming services because I
think it uh its world premiere I think
was earlier this year or late last year
I think it was at Fantastic Fest maybe
and I had heard some buzz about it and
like saw like a couple of like really
positive
use Excel box it has 5 stars yeah so I
was really happy to see it like every
horror guy that I have watched reviews
of this for like [ __ ] loved it yeah
um and I really hope that it doesn't get
because I feel like bliss didn't really
get that much attention but this one I
believe definitely should because this
is if you really like John Carpenter if
you like action horror like really
really gory ad style [ __ ] that's kind of
like has that underground punk rock kind
of scummy sort of vibe to it they will
[ __ ] love this is just a real
well-crafted low-budget movie playing to
a low budget movie strengths yeah on
moshing the golden era of that genre you
know and it's like I said it's it's uh
on on xbox it's four and a half out of
five stars that's what's being rated
I think the 5 out of 5 yeah just on the
strength I mean we had a [ __ ] ball
with this movie I would I actually
wouldn't mind seeing it again yeah I
want to buy it on blu-ray
yeah so if you was like whatever your
streaming services I don't know like
shutter might end up adding it
eventually because they have his other
movie they might have his first movie to
I'm not really sure so it's gonna go
right in there with my carpenter
collection yeah cuz it's very and I
don't want to like make it seem like
he's just ripping off John know it's a
no Maj for sure but it's it's own thing
yeah yeah carpenter Conant kind of
helped lay out a lot of the foundation
that came from a lot of this type of
movie from that era yeah and you know
the director in this case he's letting
you know you know where this movie's
supposed to go yeah and spot-on yes but
are definitely many more like this yeah
I would do actually but yeah I
definitely recommend it it's a lot of
fun the cast is great the [ __ ] gore
is fantastic yeah and it's just a blast
it's a blast to watch it's like really I
would like to see him do a monster movie
something along the lines of the of the
thing yeah wouldn't that be something
his only he's a big John Carpenter fan
I'm sure he'll probably do something
like that
yeah something kind of like a long long
long lines of thing so yeah definitely
seeing this has made me like excited to
see what he does for an escape from a
New York type thing yeah I'd like to see
him do a movie like that
yeah oh definitely actually I would
trust this dude with the character of
Snake Plissken I bet you he could run a
good [ __ ] Snake Plissken story
yeah probably probably better than
better Parminder could write action
Icona I kind of lightened up a little
bit on escape from LA I mean I just see
it as parody yeah you know I mean it is
not as it's just not as long as I'm
sitting she's not as ominous and dark as
the original yeah it was just too goofy
was a little goofy yeah and I just
couldn't I couldn't get past the
goofiness yeah just not not from that
character and not from ya know why I
don't know why I chose to do it like
that I wouldn't have done it like that
yeah it's almost kind of like he was
like taking a piss like himself or
something ya know yeah this guy's so I
can take on Snake Plissken yeah that
might be really interested yeah but yeah
definitely whatever streaming service
you have if they check it out and see if
they have it on there like I said we run
it for 399 on xbox and I'm sure other
places have it as well well we're seeing
guy so so yeah if you're into that kind
of like action horror throwback type of
stuff you definitely have to see this
it's really really good
you
so second matinee movie we saw this week
was yet another xbox rental of a movie
that came out late last year but just
drops on VOD very recently this was a
horror movie called the dare yeah I was
impressed with it this was actually much
better than I was expecting the troll
the trailer looked good you know we
watched him like a bunch of trailers of
the horror movies that are available on
Xbox rental from this year and this one
actually looked pretty good so we kind
of gave it a shot
yeah I thought it was gonna be kind of
generic you know no gasps they'll be all
right watched it and it was pretty
[ __ ] good I liked it oh yeah it was
very I mean it's it's not a super
original story it's but it's very
similar like the setup of it is kind of
similar to saw or like other kind of
yeah I don't really like to use like
torture porn but it's like that kind of
setup not quite as graphic though it's
not yeah it does have a lot of crunchy
[ __ ] you know oh you know I mean but it
doesn't actually show a lot of it it
does it like cuts away but then it's
just kind of like it's not which that's
fine with me I don't ya know I'm not
yeah I don't have to actually see it the
idea of it is it no is enough yeah
because there is like some pretty print
inducing things that happened this was
like you know people's fingernails
coming off and like their eyeballs being
cut out how can people eat bugs and make
it people swallow Wow I don't want to
steal the movie stander yeah but this
it's so it's you know I wouldn't advise
like if you're really squeamish about
violence I wouldn't advise you to watch
it but if you're like really into you
know movies that kind of show everything
and like it's like it you know kind of
where they show everything to such an
extent that that's kind of like the
whole thing of the movie it's not quite
that far but I will say that it I think
as far as I could determine from what I
looked up about this movie that all of
the special effects were practical yeah
and that CGI was only done like in
little touches here and there like to
clean things up but others I mean the
special effects in this are really good
yeah I I chipped out and I got a
standard definition I think was worth
$2.99
$3.99 I think God has spent the extra
dollar to get the HD version on it
actually I think yeah but really the
strong point of the movie is really the
the story and the cast I liked the story
it was kind of like you said a little
bit like saw but also a little bit like
Friday the 13th there's a Jacobin
character but it also shows his origin
story and then and it had a good cast it
had the bat had that bad guy from
Hannibal rising he was also in Mandy I
think one name was your break yeah
anyway there he was in three from hell
as well yeah he played the the the dude
that made the [ __ ] killer acid [ __ ]
yeah that skinny skinny guy what's his
name yeah Richard break yeah he was good
in it he's kind of like the I guess you
could say he's like the main villain but
then there's like a secondary villain
and this actor here man he really stood
out for me ever the whole cast was good
yeah he was creepy as hell in this yeah
the whole cast in this was good you know
the people that are playing the victims
and the [ __ ] main guy and everything
he was he was really good in it but the
one that stood out to me was [ __ ] the
villain in this the guy who kind of
plays comic Dominic his name is Dominic
he's almost kind of like Jason but he
talks oh yeah
and this actor man a just impressed me
he's he's a big dude about like Arnold
we when Aldo became an actor he wasn't
as big as Arnold say when Arnold was
lifting but you know when he was
competing but when he was an actors
about that size
he's a young guy and takes off that damn
mask in this is just one handsome dude
man I was looking like damn I didn't
expect him to look like that and that
really played out well in the movie yeah
I look like a [ __ ] Calvin Klein model
but he could act yeah it was unexpected
I like the Wizards I don't reverse that
trope cuz you know how like in the
Friday the 13th movies when Jason's
hockey mask comes off at his face is all
[ __ ] up yeah this day almost kind of
did an obligatory subversion of that
rabbit right and it's a really good
character that I think he's playing but
I'm really am
with this actor and Jenny I was like I
saw a dude I go meant there's your next
Terminator right there it said that dude
could straighten his hair and [ __ ]
diet black that's the [ __ ] terminator
and Jenny goes actually [ __ ] Flash
Gordon and I was like yeah daddy like
woulda play flash that dude would play
an awesome Flash Gordon cuz he looks
like a hero
oh man yeah you know he looks here's I
forgot to say this morning cuz I looked
him up like after I talked to you
his name is Robert ma soeur he's
actually German okay um he started out
as a gymnast okay and he has like a
whole bunch of titles for doing a we
he's a wheel gymnast you know like those
big loops than they do like all the
[ __ ] tricks over the rolling loops
and stuff he actually started out in
show business as a stunt man yeah and he
his first international screen debut was
in Mission Impossible rogue nation okay
he was I love that movie I hope I can
see it
this dude needs to be a star man he was
also in 1917 he was the German pilot in
the plane that oh that was him - all
right yeah yeah I didn't realize his
view if I didn't right yeah he had that
flight gear on you yeah I didn't
recognize him but yeah that was yeah
this dude right and I called it I didn't
realize he was German yes you know you
can't tell he he doesn't have an accent
dude can act um I was thinking man that
dad dude is like another Arnold
Schwarzenegger yeah he belongs in movies
I'd like to see him in action series
well it seems like he's starting out
she's not doing damn good yeah like I
said he's a stuntman gymnast I see in
really good shape our Wars is [ __ ] up
that's not coming back I don't think you
know even know the baby you had a thing
that looks that sounds evidently people
like that Star Wars was a ripoff of
Flash Gordon well I guess he couldn't
make cuz Lucas couldn't get a license
gonna get a license well actually I
think at the time Dino De Laurentiis
Studios had it yeah and then you want to
give to him which I love that movie live
people don't like it but you see that
[ __ ] in HD would look like I'm gonna on
the big screen it looked really good
[ __ ] Star Wars what they should do is
somebody just come back and bring Flash
Gordon and put this dude in it as Flash
Gordon I think he'd make a really good
place yeah what was good about [ __ ]
Flash Gordon this
it was [ __ ] wild it had sex and drugs
in it the original the original glass
cord did you know scantily clad women
[ __ ] slave girls and you know Ming
the Merciless and all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] was happening even in the old
black-and-white flash Gordon's if you
read into it yeah yeah that's what they
were talking about and why don't just go
back to Flash Gordon put this they've
tried to reboot Flash Gordon so many
times and it always sucked it never did
right the DeLaurentis woman was the
closest one I think when now with modern
CG you could make real Flash Gordon and
that [ __ ] would be cool pink skies and
green outer space and windows on the air
on spaceships and everything yeah I
think it'd be all right you know you've
gotta get back to this one yeah I was
gonna say so we're talking about this
movie so like I said now this is the
first it's not the directorial debut
exactly but it's the fictional
full-length movie director directorial
debut of a guy named Kyle's Alderson who
was British
now he's apparently also an actor he's
made documentaries he's made short films
he's made all that kind of stuff but
this is like his first you know
feature-length film and apparently this
got like a kind of a festival run like
in the UK and in the Netherlands late
last year and then it just got released
you know just recently on VOD platforms
now the set up of it like I said it's
it's similar to saw in that there's like
a very brief kind of thing where you're
introduced to a family the Jackson
family and it's like you know husband
wife two daughters and you know there's
some kind of hints that Jay spends a lot
of time like away from home because he's
trying to you know make more money so
they can move out of this house and and
the wife doesn't really like it because
he's gone all the time so there's like a
there's probably like a three or four
minute thing where that's established
and then pretty much it seems there's an
intruder outside and then BAM suddenly
Jay the dad wakes up chained up in a
basement yeah with all three other
people and when I was badly mangled and
one of them's all mangled and can't talk
like it I think his lips are so together
or something like that so as it goes on
like he tries to escape he tries to like
figure out what the
is going on and all the time that this
is going on there's also like a parallel
story and for the first part of the
movie I was a little bit confused
because I thought that was going on
simultaneously like from that because
they kind of hinted that it was going on
at the same time but as the movie goes
on it's like no it's established that
that was like a flashback you know what
I mean so it's like that went on
previously and then like as there's also
kind of like a mystery element because
you're trying to figure out what are
these four people that are chained in
this basement have in common and why is
this particular person doing this to
them and why is he doing this particular
thing in this particular way and you
know so the two stories kind of go
parallel with the present in the past
Richard brake plays you know the guy in
the past with it
so so those two kind of go and then like
as it goes on you kind of figure out
more and more about the situation and
what's happening with it and like I said
it's it's not like a really like
mind-blowingly original concept or
anything like that but I thought it was
really well executed I thought like the
acting was good I've seen a little bit
of criticism that you know old none of
the characters are all that likable
which no that's why I can see that but
the main guy Jay who's played by Bart
Edwards he's likable in the sense that
you know you can he has a wife and kids
who obviously love him and you know even
if he did do something bad like to
quote-unquote deserve this like just you
know imagining yourself in that
situation and him trying to get out of
that situation and you know having
frustration with these other two people
who seem to have become like completely
like you know we can't escape from here
and all this other kind of [ __ ] so that
interaction I thought made him more
sympathetic yeah as the story unfolds
you you understand why they're not
likable yeah by accident all right so
yeah that's you could say that the
story's not that original but Jenny and
I are almost at two different opposite
ends of the spectrum she's likes it
she's reeling a story into the story and
innovation and stuff I don't like that I
like things that are kind of familiar
and traditional and real enjoyable that
don't require a lot
thinking I guess you could say yeah
unless I want to think about it for me
movies escapism I just want to be
entertained thank you but it depends on
as I what is the motive for me I thought
the movie was very entertaining it was
kind of a traditional horror movie kind
of situation that I'm used to 80s 90s
you know it it's fast paced very fast
pace I have a very short attention span
and as soon as the movies started I
can't watch it yeah like there was only
a little bit of character development
running with him in the family just to
establish it and then it just went right
in if a movie takes a [ __ ] weird turn
or something it gets all boring and it
didn't do it
so I enjoyed the movie and I really
liked and I and once I figured out like
that the two plots were happening not
simultaneously but we're happy because I
thought it was like upstairs downstairs
but it's actually like two different
time periods and once I had figured that
out and the parallels and everything I
was like okay so I kind of got that
going so I thought that was like a
little bit of an original yeah kind of
thing where they kept going back and
forth in the timelines without really
making it clear at the beginning that
that's what they were doing because it
seemed to me that they were trying to at
first trying to make you think that it
was going on at the same time but then
later
for me I had just as much fun watching
this one as I did VFW I like the fw2
yeah you know they're very different
movies but they were equally
entertaining yeah this one is very much
more like I said I hate to use torture
porn but you know I use that because
people know what I'm talking about
it's very much in that vein probably not
as graphic it's not like hostile or
something like that because a lot of the
effects while amazing and realistic
looking they don't like dwell like put
on like put them right in your face you
know it was suggested yeah which in a
way I thought kind of like better like
kind of left it to your imagination like
because you're sitting there going you
could see what was coming it was time to
see that and you were like nasty and in
this one the story is more really kind
of more important than that than the
damn gore anyway yeah he asked me it was
more about the story and how what the
hell was why how'd this happen yeah
that's why I was going
and what the hell because that's what
kept me watching I'm like well who are
these four people and why are they here
and yet who's this dude and why is he
doing this and it's a good story yeah I
mean I liked it a lot like I said up
first for an it for us equal to its set
up for a sequel that's yeah that's right
if their bday yeah cuz I remember that
little code yeah there is set up for a
sequel so you know they're trying to
make a property sound blame oh I'd watch
a sequel well I kind of feel like even
most investors even in independent
movies are kind of maybe looking for the
next big thing that's gonna become like
a franchise that they can make a lot of
money on so it's like you know everybody
loves trilogies and he loves like
expanded universe and they got that they
got this they got this guy's kind of
like a cross between a Freddy Krueger
and a and a Jason and a and a [ __ ] my
car guy from the collector and I got in
the collector he's a big guy
big crate [ __ ] but he's [ __ ]
weird and it's good yeah I I actually
liked it agree yeah and he didn't come
out of nowhere he was kind of trained to
be this yeah he had a mentor who made
him into this [ __ ] I liked it yeah
yeah really good so yeah it's streaming
on various platforms we got on an Xbox
but I saw that it was for rent other
places maybe Amazon Prime or something
like that I can't remember exactly but
like level yeah I saw several other ones
but yeah he's you know four or five
bucks [ __ ] yeah it's a good watch if you
love horror movies and especially its
brand new yeah and brainy oh so
definitely check it out
you
all right third movie we saw this week
on the met nay was yet another Xbox
rental this one was like a horror
thriller from Canada called true fiction
now this was the trailer for this looks
really good but the trailer is looked
really good and but I have to say that
the trailer they very deceptive well
they did this on purpose because they
wanted it to go so in a way I liked that
because you thought it was gonna go one
direction and then it goes in a wildly
different direction to what you thought
it was gonna happen but yeah so
basically the setup of this has a little
bit of a touch of misery type of thing
to it it kind of Stephen King II type a
set up it was actually shot in Calgary I
think in Alberta so basically there's
this girl named Avery and she is an
aspiring writer she works at a library
she comes across as like slightly maybe
a little mousy little insecure something
like that but she's like this big fan of
a horror writer named Caleb Conrad who
very famously is reclusive like no one
has ever seen his face so she gets
chosen to work for this reclusive author
that she looked so much out in his
remote [ __ ] cabin or whatever like
out in the [ __ ] snow and she's super
jacked about it and when she gets there
she discovers that he has been having I
guess some kind of writer's block
so he's like what I wanted to do was get
somebody in here and do some like
controlled experiments in fear as he
calls them and try to get his muse back
and he's like and I want to like write a
book together like about you and about
like all the fear and [ __ ] like that
that you're doing so he does kind of
like standard then like he puts her in a
sensory deprivation suit and shows her
like all these like really [ __ ] up
images he seems to be like filming her
when she's sleepy like just doing this
kind of messed-up stuff he like locks
her in this one wing of the cabin starts
Gaslight
and starts gaslighting her and [ __ ]
with her and stuff like a you didn't see
that in that video and like all this
other kind of stuff which was really
like stressing me I was like well I was
watching this because that's like I
don't know that
bothers me a lot but it's like I really
don't want to I really don't want to
spoil this because it went in a
direction I was really not expecting and
I like the direction that it went in
because if you just like watched the
trailer you would think that this was a
pretty standard like you know this woman
goes to this cabin and is kept you know
it's like held hostage by this crazy
writer who's doing all these like
experiments on her and stuff and it does
seem like that's what it's about
but then reality starts to become a
little more amorphous like you're not
really sure you you're not really sure
like who is the instigator you're not
really sure what is really have like
what's really real what's fake are some
of the people actors you don't really
there's like all this all these kind of
like tendrils going on in this movie
that make it like kind of go off in like
a a really interesting direction which I
wasn't expecting so like I said I'm
really glad that it went that way
instead of just being another standard
you know woman held captive by crazy
person thing and then like she fights
back and everything if this actually
went in a different way and it's like I
said I don't really want to spoil it and
it's kind of hard to talk about but it's
like there's like a lot of there's
pretty much only two characters in this
the girl that was in and I think she's
been on like some TV shows and stuff the
guy that plays the writer I think he was
in seven and he's been in a like a
couple other movies like it I had seen
him before and like some other [ __ ]
so it's essentially mostly just the two
of them like interacting and it's really
creepy because he doesn't seem I mean he
seems a little bit sinister but not
really he also seems kind of like you
know mild-mannered and [ __ ] but just the
the way that they psychologically like
interact with each other is really
really interesting to watch and I really
really liked you know how it kind of
goes in a direction where you're not
really sure who's telling the truth or
what exactly is going on and this is
definitely one that I will probably need
to watch again because I feel like there
was a lot of stuff go
there that I missed you know what I mean
um because it's it gets like really
complicated and there's like all this
[ __ ] going on I'm still not entirely
sure if see I don't want to say if
certain people were who they said they
were you know what I mean like they
don't really I don't know if they really
resolve that or if I just wasn't paying
attention but yeah it's like this was a
really good one it I guess it premiered
at a film festival like a horror
festival in Brazil last May and
subsequently went on to VOD I haven't
heard a lot of people talking about I've
seen like some horror blogs and stuff
like that a lot of them have reviewed it
it seems to be getting it's weird cuz I
am Debbie it has like fairly low ratings
but most of the reviewers I saw
particularly one guy that I liked and I
came from what is a channel is called
but he's Canadian also and he really
really liked this movie and he was like
trying to get it ready to watch it and
most of the horror blogs that I've seen
of like really enjoyed it like I said
it's not fantastic it's probably not
even my favorite one that we saw this
week which would be VFW obviously but
it's certainly worth watching especially
if you like psychological horror
it's got like some gore and it's kind of
bloody like toward the end but that's
like you know the third act it's it's
kind of a slow setup you know what I
mean and maybe they may be like they
could have done a little bit more with
Avery's characterization at the
beginning but then in some ways that was
a reason why they didn't like it made
sense with the story and like if you've
seen it you'll know what I'm talking
about
but um yeah definitely a good
psychological horror film I feel like I
said it's a little bit of a slow build
but it gets like gory and Barker's like
in the third act so you know that sounds
like something that you'd be into then
check it out
it's probably like for rent on other
beauty platforms as well yeah I didn't
like it yeah I know I didn't like it
it broke a lot of the rules it's just
not to my taste I mean five to ten
minute rule broken which is you know if
it doesn't it doesn't get doesn't get
and hold my attention to that first five
to ten minutes it's not going to be any
good from my point of view it's not the
kind of movie I like
long winded no score to speak of kind of
stale the acting's not bad but that's
not saying much it not bad is not the
same as good yeah
just uh no to dialogue heavy well this
is definitely one where you have to pay
attention everything that's going on and
like I said it's a psychological horror
yeah that's I was gonna say I don't
think this is a horror movie it's a
horror thriller yeah it's a psycho drama
thriller type it is like its gory at the
end like there's violence and it gets
bloody at the end but most of it is like
the interaction between the two
characters like the disturbing images
she goes through like with you you know
with in the sensory deprivation thing
where he's trying to like freak her out
and him doing like lie-detector tests on
her and all this other so it's kind of
like the cat and mouse like the
interaction between the two of them is
like the large part so you know so if
you're looking for something that's more
like you know like the one we that we
reviewed yesterday the Dare then it's
not like that yeah more like something
also about the audio mastering it sounds
like the audio was kind of like off a
video camera more than something on a
movie to me I didn't he didn't notice
that no I didn't yeah the audio quality
was sounded kinda it didn't sound
theatrical it sounded more like
something off a damn video camera just
wait sounded the audio mix was weird I
didn't notice anything
yeah about it well when they spoke there
is something about something about yeah
I'm not I'm not you know an audio expert
there's just something about it it's out
of cheap hmm yeah I just did yeah I
don't know well you know what I mean I
didn't really notice anything unusual
but then again my hearing isn't all that
yeah that sounded a little bit I think I
think something I think a story like
this would be better in a book than it
would be a movie yeah like I said this
came across it's very Stephen King II
it's not you know I don't want to say
it's just like misery because the story
is very different but in the sense of
you know writers in an isolated cabin
like one of whom is
ostensibly being kept captive by the
other one so and then like the whole
psychological thing between the two of
them so it's similar in that sense so if
that sounds like something that you
would like then I do recommend it Tom
didn't like it no I would have edited it
a lot of it down yeah you know it's not
really that long I think it was only an
hour and 45 minutes on bed and confusing
yeah I mean very heavy and dialogue and
it didn't seem like the dialogue was
important it was but like I said it was
definitely somebody I liked that kind of
thing right okay it's just a taste yeah
for me cinema is something you sit there
and you watch it you entertained it
you're entertained you go on a journey
you know you don't really have to think
about it too much or if you do you know
I just that's just how I watch movies
yeah I don't really want to sit around
to figure out somebody's puzzle yes yeah
well I like I said I like all kind of
movies like I like just stupid fun ones
too but it's like I really do like one
that you know you really have to watch
like a second or third time like to get
all the nuances and like see everything
that was going on like I like that kind
of thing you know I mean I like it a
little more emotional more visual less
less dialogue ya know I don't like that
I don't like stories that are driven
that way yeah you know a story like that
I think the best best medium would be
book yeah I can see this working out as
a book as well yeah I think it'd be
better as a book yeah I think was
written as like you know a screenplay /
play / okay let's make this into a movie
and taking something from a book into a
movie is difficult I mean look at the
difference between the shining book and
the movie they're both excellent but the
movies nothing like the book
not really he tried to make the shining
into a damn movie what you get is you
get the TV series that you like that I
like that TV series but I didn't like it
the most of it didn't like it right
because it was too literal dude yeah
well that's what this kind of felt yeah
I don't know I mean the guy that like I
said the guy that did this is Canadian
this is his third movie as far as I know
but I haven't seen his other two so I
couldn't tell you like how this stood in
relation to just kind of just kind of
lost me in the beginning when it was
really focused around this girl and her
and this and that and it went on a
little little too long and I really
don't care about movie character movies
that much the characters in the movies
it's hard to get me connected to some
character in a movie just a dialogue
yeah yeah oh man
so I through visual stuff but you can
might get me connected but not the
dialogue yeah you know I guess it's part
of my just personal operating system I
pretty much ignore what people say I'm
mostly watching what they're doing yeah
okay I don't know just maybe its defense
back and just being bamboozled a lot
yeah
you be you talking but I'm just watching
your hands [ __ ] looking at your body
language more anything else you know
[ __ ] what could decisions have you
made and stuff like dick how did you
react to this and that you know I don't
really care what you said you know
people can say anything so it's hard to
draw me into stories there with dialogue
I think yeah yeah but you know so I
think that you know both of us coming at
it from a different perspective I think
that that will be like whatever kind of
person you are whether you're a person
like Tom are you more person like me
that'll probably know you know that'll
say whether you like the movie or not
which i think is very handy yeah so yeah
that sounds like something you'd like
then definitely go watch it it's I
thought it was like pretty damn decent
like I said not not my favor of the week
that was VFW cuz that was just you know
fun and bloody and gory and everything
and this one like you know it is one
that you definitely need like to invest
like your full attention and because
it's like very complicated like as the
story goes on like you know what's going
on and who's who and stuff like that but
yeah check it out
[Music]